[Music]
diabetes is one of the fastest-growing
health crises of our time in Britain the
National Health Service spends 10
billion pounds per year treating it
that's almost 10 percent of the entire
national health budget by 2040 it's
estimated that one in ten people around
the world will have the disease three
decades of healthy lifestyle advice have
failed to make an impact could surgery
be the answer
[Music]
being a fisherman all my life I can't
tell you how much Amish to see I love my
wife and children obviously what
fishings a passion this isn't just a job
Peter Hansel is 68 a few years ago he
was diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
when I was diagnosed I didn't think it
would have the restrictions it had on my
life
he just wasn't served for me to be at
sea so diabetes has stopped me working
which upsets me greatly type 2 diabetes
is a serious condition in which the body
can't use insulin properly ninety
percent of people with diabetes have
type two type one is much rarer and
usually develops in childhood the
prognosis is that parts of my body will
deteriorate over time my kidneys my
heart have all of a sudden tons of
ghetto from gore would I'm afraid they
get up on Goya's got up and gone
globally the number of people with type
2 diabetes has quadrupled in the past
four decades it's been branded as a
lifestyle illness brought on by poor
diet and lack of exercise obesity is a
major risk factor but one doctor is
convinced that the disease is
misunderstood if we were as simple as
telling people to eat less and
exercising more we've been giving this
message for the past thirty years and as
a result we haven't seen any change can
be academic has continued to grow
professor Francesco Rubino specializes
in weight loss surgery he's performed
hundreds of gastric bypass operations on
obese patients but Rubino has discovered
that gastric surgery
has a profound and unexpected side
effect
found that many of the patients who have
bariatric operations would experience a
complete remission of diabetes almost
overnight to me that was too much to be
explained by weight loss alone and I
thought what if there is something else
dr. Rapinoe is now going to operate on
Peter
not because he's Abby's but to treat his
diabetes by changing the anatomy of his
gut Rubino believes that a section of
the small intestine doesn't work
properly in people with diabetes
Peter stomach will be divided and
re-routed so that food no longer passes
through the 40 section something happens
in dinner leaning which contributes to
be a mechanism of diabetes and by
bypassing that segment we're bypassing
what could be the source of the problem
[Music]
when food moves through the small
intestine a complex hormone signaling
system tells the brain to stop eating
and stimulates the pancreas to produce
insulin a Fault in this signalling
system would make it extremely difficult
for the patient to control their eating
and could explain why the body can't
regulate insulin properly Peter sends a
very good chance of having a complete
remission of diabetes and this is an
effect that was not even conceived as
possible just until a few years ago the
effect is so striking that in 2016
international medical guidelines were
changed to include surgery as a main
treatment option for some diabetes
patients but very few have come forward
despite the evidence suggesting that
these interventions are so affected in
many cases they are life-saving there
are probably 0.1 to 1% of individual who
meet the criteria for surgery who
actually access to it type 2 diabetes is
widely viewed as a lifestyle disease
that patients can control on their own
without the need for surgery but Rubino
believes this is a misconception having
an operation is not an experience that
everybody would be prepared to have
however the evidence we have so far has
shown time and again that once you have
become diabetic hope once you have very
severe obesity changing your lifestyle
alone is not going to bring the benefits
that are needed in clinical trials
Rubino is testing other ways to prevent
food interacting with the faulty section
of the intestine such as plastic tubing
or eradicating cells from the gut wall
the hope is that in the future patients
like Peter won't need to have invasive
surgery 7 weeks after the operation and
Peter's health has taken a dramatic turn
I just feel good I can just do what I
want I've got a life again I can't thank
professor ravine on his team enough for
what they did for me I haven't took any
insulin since
for now at least Peters diabetes is in
remission surgery alone can't halt the
epidemic diabetes rates are rising in
almost every country but only a few have
the resources for surgery
prevention through better diet and
lifestyle is vital but if surgery can
uncover the cause of diabetes
perhaps a cure will follow
[Music]
you